how many [ __ ] me up Old Yeller classic
hey reject nation it's gray I'll be here
[Applause]
Sally Lomonaco was with me today you've
seen how it should have ended right
solid back and forth we got going on
today yeah well they got a comedy recap
of a movie classic predator figured what
the predator coming out this week we
should watch this and considering that
so many comments are asking us to do
this I figured who better than the woman
who looks like the predator herself no
you kind of do that's why we never had
off-camera chemistry follower on
everything Laurel she'll yeah that's two
that like how much head space you get
yeah that's
[Music]
[Music]
that's a bad guy time for payback
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you dead what keeps attacking us
don't dumb your dog he's right it's an
alien everyone's going crazy what do you
think
[Music]
Alexa gonna win that dream of gonna
catch the brightest one
oops we forgot the bait he's not here
[Music]
I'd see it do you see it
you ready kill it no let's split up
oh okay if you say so I mean I really
think we should have stayed together
what's that good thing I'm the main
character that means I'll still give me
a gun no it won't kill you if you don't
have a gun I'll just drop her stupid
yeah Oh Billy's dead
[Music]
in such clothes both shouting phrase
here I'll get to the choppa no more bad
to us now
[Music]
oh thanks worthy of what
[Music]
oh please
haha looks like
[Music]
I suddenly feel sorry for you even
though you're just cute I know you're
not supposed to text during the movie
[Music]
there's no way anyone gonna survive that
I lived I live through everything hey
Dutch
I hear they're gonna make a sequel I
won't be back like 15 Terminator movies
oh gosh I would have watched a full two
hours of that I saw the honest trailers
recently for a predator that was really
funny and then this stuff is oh yeah I
wish I wish they would recap every movie
this one every movie
I love the voices they're chosen you
gotta get the armlet voice in there but
then I love how the Predators voice
sounded like I watched this movie we
watched it about a week ago to go back
and watch this or even oh he didn't harm
me because you don't have a gun we all
just drop a guns in like random moments
that I really loved yours when he hits
the girl I love how they cut this down
too because they obviously can't show a
lot of the gourd and stuff for else
YouTube will give it a lot of crap I
thought they actually did a really good
job at slicing this and for doing a
comedy recap in the Matt I've seen recap
videos of many many movies but to do
like a comedy recap where I feel like if
you didn't see the predator or it's been
decades since you see the predator you
can watch this and be like remember
always that promised you you would just
be stuck with this image in your head
remember what the hizzy version of it is
I mean the voiceovers that you could
hear a lot of the voice-over some their
animated videos I thought they'd use
some good effect to with just the mouth
movement because a lot of that like
great comedy effect right there I
thought this was a really great way to
like make fun of the movie but also kind
of honor the movie simultaneously I
loved like the little touches of when
they're shooting the like
grenade launchers and it goes like oh
yeah these like cute little noises yeah
they did a great job on this video dude
because this is like a 90-minute film
what more can you say other than this
video is like [ __ ] absolutely
hysterical man thank you guys I thank
you for making this I'm so happy we
watch this right now alright guys well
thanks for tuning in please subscribe
dizzy a half-assed attempt at that get
to the job
why is your throat hurts ally hey Sally
why does your throat click the
notification and you have a more poorly
follow Sally on everything yeah take
care guys